uh the republican civil war is
continuing to ramp up donald trump
completely completely losing it and
asking for mitch mcconnell to be removed
immediately as the senate minority
leader and it is a tale of contrasts in
the united states in the last two months
on the one hand the biden administration
with the most stunning 180
a seemingly dying presidency two and a
half months ago
the number of biden accomplishments is
incredible we talked about it earlier
and on the other hand look at what is
happening in the american right wing
donald trump posting on his platform
truth social just hours ago
the democrats have mitch mcconnell and
his lovely wife elaine koko chow
over a barrel
he and she will never be prosecuted as
per the last paragraphs of this story as
long as he continues to give the radical
left the trillions and trillions of
dollars that they constantly demand he
was afraid to use the debt ceiling card
in order to stop the most expensive
waste of money in our country's history
to be spent on the green new deal which
will only cause one thing a depression
and then donald trump posting a
statement that by the way
elaine koko chow that's trump's uh
former secretary of transportation
now just attacking her ridiculing her
and then donald trump um uh putting out
the uh following statement where he says
much of the same things
and then adds these expenditures are
something our country can never recover
from mitch mcconnell is not an
opposition leader he is a pawn for the
democrats to get whatever they want he
is afraid of them and will not do what
has to be done a new republican leader
in the senate should be picked
immediately
listen
i welcome this
i welcome this republican infighting it
can only help the odds improve for
democrats in the house and in the senate
now it's still bad in the house
democrats will almost certainly lose the
house based on the numbers as of today
if those numbers shift between now and
november we will see that and i will let
you know
but i welcome this completely and
totally wholeheartedly i hope that
donald trump continues to push this
i can't imagine imagine a better infight
before the midterms then should we
completely get rid of and push out mitch
mcconnell one of the most long-standing
and powerful republicans when there is a
fight between
listen i like adam kinzinger okay but
he's not like the most well-known
republican he's not the most powerful
republican it's great that he came out
against trump i still disagree with him
on most policy fine
we're talking about mitch mcconnell here
and the growing fight between the maggo
wing
and the sort of
establishment wing of the republican
party is absolutely fantastic and one of
the things that could be particularly
good about this is that most
congressional republicans and i mean
house and senate
are going to stand behind mitch
mcconnell
but they also aren't likely to publicly
oppose donald trump
and
as long as trump doesn't come out and
say you have to swear allegiance to me
you have to swear loyalty to me as long
as trump doesn't do that they can
probably get away with what is an absurd
wishy-washy position at the end of the
day which is well we stand behind mitch
mcconnell
but we also support trump if he's the
nominee or whatever
the
dream scenario will be
trump actually demands that more and
more republicans swear some kind of oath
of loyalty to trump and or disavow mitch
mcconnell publicly and it will get
really ugly really quickly democrats
should encourage this and it is a
beautiful thing
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa i have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs i have not one but
two all form sofas i've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable furniture i own
and it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements
that is definitely not something you get
from your typical sofa company all form
has everything from eight piece
sectionals to love seats and arm chairs
everything is made in the usa using
premium materials all form makes sure
that assembly is really easy i didn't
even need any tools which is good
because i have very few tools and you
can keep the sofa for over three months
and send it back free if you don't like
it for a full refund
right now all form is giving my audience
20 off all orders at allform.com
pacman the link is down below